de façon générale ce qu'on voit c'est
que dans cette profusion de
l'information parce qu'évidemment il y
en a il y en a beaucoup c'est pas qu'il
manque des informations et des analyses
ou deux à bignan c'est justement le fait
qu'il y en a tellement
mais qui circulent dans des réseaux
différents parfois même distincts au
séparer plus la manipulation plus le
poids de l'argent au niveau des
campagnes électorales la propagande de
la publicité etc tout ça c'est que
finalement plutôt qu'à voir cet idéal
démocratique qui était celui de la
réflexion de la delà de la délibération
où l'on oppose des arguments des cetc
ont signé par bon faire jouer les images
on peut un peu à la façon justement de
de la publicité ce qui t'attire à moins
d'un terrain on va choisir un leader
plus parce que on aime on le trouve bon
beau et pas trop donc sur le plan
personnel alors que on devrait attirer
du moins démocratie ne discutait que des
idées et ceux qui les portent ses idées
ses projets bon c'est ces personnes
qu'on va élire mais c'est pas on va se
tourner vers tel ou tel candidat parce
que parce qu'on le trouve sympa et c'est
donc je pense qu'effectivement on a un
problème dans tout le monde démocratique
par rapport à cela l'idée que ont choisi
en fonction de l'image et de préférence
un peu superficielle plutôt que sur le
fond des problèmes quand il a fait face